servus skates und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge einer neuen folge mehr
aus jump wollten mit dem w
mit hallo und herzlich willkommen und
wir spielen heute wieder eine neue folge
es den elefanten das heißt ich dagegen
wenig an mit maps hier dafür gebaut auf
dem pult und besucher zwar wieder raus
hier oben es den elefanten und nach
bewertung sortieren darum ist ihr euch
eine bewertung besser frühjahr genau
heute habe ich vergessen zu sagen heißt
wer zuerst zwei maps gewonnen hatte hat
die folge gewonnen
exakt und das nächste video kommt dann
ging's bei dir ja okay let's go es den
elefanten bei texxas hd ich blende ich
erst mal direkt aus okay das ist ja auch
ich lese die checks konnte dinge hier
nicht schilder ist schon was mache ich
denn mit gott
richtig ich richtig bitter gerade dass
die runde hast du da wurde gerade
gefragt wird warum gewonnen war 1 gewann
muss ich auch kurz mal kurz mal
überlegen habe ich satt
zack zack leute hier und da unten kommt
eher wenig war
jetzt geht's ab schnell schnell das ziel
sehe noch nicht weiter es ist noch
ziemlich weiß jackpot fünf alter noch
gut ist habe ich ihn nicht nicht
geschaut müssen gasgemischen gas gmbh
sollen auf ursprünge der kammer keine
zeit obwohl das problem ist das weiß ich
dass es das ist natürlich für mich als
auto-fan eine leichte frage hier
demnächst in welche reihe von audi gibt
es nicht das weiß natürlich bin ich aber
auch leute ich bin nämlich momentan
starken überlegen ob ich mir so ein auto
zulegen kann glaube ich mach's nicht
aber ich schaue den ganzen tag auf den
einschlägig bekannten online portal nach
auf und ja ich war das aber auch weiß
ich natürlich das war auch nicht so
schwer
geht das geht aber welcher hersteller
hat hat der m serie erzählt dass bmw
abgefragt wer hat war o2 gewonnen es war
unglaublich wenig kraft und msi experten
ist ja so wenn man es regelkonform
update eigentlich schon jetzt können die
ganzen welt gefragt
ich glaube ich hab nichts geschenkt was
ist das
man muss irgendwie glaube ich in das
portal
darüber eine wtf
da ich dachte ich habe jetzt sind wir
eingezogen das findet es ja das finde
ich fragen ist muss auch die richtige
antwort geben
er steht auch nicht recht
ich bin ganz so schlecht kommen ich habe
keine ahnung alter wie oft oder
instagram vom place tage dauern oder was
ist das the places ist der app store von
android ja arbeitet das heißt ja nicht
wieviel liebe sei die insgesamt haben
die finalisten player oder das sind
ähnlich viele leute benutzen weiß ich
also es unter einer milliarde sage ich
jetzt als irgend statistik gesehen was
hast du musst das aber glaub ich falsch
weil ich habe erst heute gelesen bei
dieser ganze instrument was sie gerade
ab jetzt dass sich das ändert was er gar
nicht in medias das ist nur firma user
gibt ja genau denkt denkt immer weiter
lesen
aber das ist richtig gut aufgebaut für
diese sau gut gemacht einfach weil man
wenn man so aufholen kann man alles
anhand seines wissens oder damit habe
ich aber wieder davon ist das golden
ich verstehe nicht was ja als ob das
nein
die ganze volk nicht geredet
das paradoxe situation meisterte bist
der boss sein erbauer texxas hd felix
ändern im crafter die leute grüßen euch
saugut
dann spielt die zweite map kommt von
superbad pvp und doktorwürde superband
hobby ist longbottom epsons er sein
studium lasse die nicht aus
okay leute und es geht los rippel 1,2
ich glaube richtig schnell unterwegs ich
mache also keine face bisher schon
naja mega viele als ob das team hinter
mir glücklich ja ich bin aber auch
schnell wieder
nein und ich sage fans wieder wind also
du bist ja noch kein einziges und hast
du ja dass carol m 4 bei stevia blätter
aufgeht ist alles klar
die nullrunde das auch so gemacht hier
mal ein altes ja diese ganzen staates
mittelpunkt ja diese thema stage ist
saugeil um gespielt okay da bin ich bald
da kommt man da ich hab so oder hallo
durchschaut
es wird trikot dass meine statement
kräfte wenig kraft direkt runter
gefallen wissen elefant auf jeden fall
jetzt konzentrieren körper runter
ich bin sowas von direkt und indirekt
noch ein elefant warum ist angekommen es
kommt er wohl ändern
jawoll er wollte wohl überholt überholt
und jetzt hab ich nämlich frau das
gespielt
jetzt kommen wollen jetzt ist das dmc
expert stage alter schwede lässt level
westers ist es neblig das nehmen die
könnte sein
ort
er wollte es nicht und als ob ich das
ist wohl ihr aber so okay okay
jawoll egal alter schwede da war die
gold plate war haben wir zu ende bekommt
habe ich gar nicht gecheckt man direkt
hinterher
irgendwohin gegangen
solche gar nicht realisiert dass in
diensten der stadt suchen wirklich rein
ganzen track pack wir haben zwei stunden
gebraucht die map zu bauen bewertet fair
ich hab glaub ich dreimal sehr gut rein
gehauen ich bin immer sehr sehr netter
bewährter abwarte moment mal zehn waren
war nicht neben- oder dann eben nicht
dabei bei steak logo war dabei und 10
war gewinnt zeit dass mit dem tnt aber
alle auch blatt vorliege
sehr cool also leute wenn ihr die
abonnieren wollt klickt einfach in
minecraft besteht hier drauf leute
siehst du das hier guck mal was am ende
magst du die map ja nein ja sagt
gewinnst du einfach nicht dem schild es
ist mein haushalt massiv okay sollte ich
an danke soweit fürs zuschauen zwar
richtig spannend alter perfekte folgen
lernen wenn es elf minuten aufgenommen
nächste sorge dafür dass ich nicht so
viel geredet habe aber es war einfach
nur glück nur hören sind gespannt
ok wenigsten verlinkt leute abonniert
den und rein was gut da